Comendo ou não, você provavelmente ouviu sobre o Gluten. Com a crescente demanda de produtos sem gluten
Muitas pessoas se perguntam - O que é isso? Ou melhor, se você
deve comê-lo
Simplesmente, Gluten é uma combinação de 2 proteínas, encontradas primeiramente em farinha e grãos relativos
como cevada e centeio. É isso - é só proteína! Essas duas proteínas juntas chamadas de Gliadina
e glutenina juntas, criando gluten, que ajuda a nutrir os embriões de plantas, e é
um grande componente, em dar às comidas aquele mastigação boa! É como se fosse
cola - ele deixa a massa maleável e dá ao pão aquela propriedade de 'esponja'
Então, por que é tão ruim? Bom.. Não é. Na verdade, ele nem é prejudicial ou essencial para
a sua saúde! E tem muito pouca evidência que sugere que tirá-lo da sua dieta é a opção mais saudável
para a pessoa normal. No outro lado, aqueles com uma doença crônica de distúrbio digestivo
chamada de doença celíaca não podem comer nada com gluten, e é aí que a confusão
apareceu.
Se consumido, o corpo dos celíacos vê o gluten como um invasor e provoca uma resposta imune
que acaba por ser prejudicial ao intestino pequeno. Muito disso, e o corpo deles começa a
sofrer deficiências nutritivas maiores. Mais recentemente, cientistas reconheceram outra
menor proporção da população que ainda não é celíaca mas têm sensibilidade ao gluten, ou seja,
sofrem sintomas similares depois de comerem gluten - como dor de estômago, diarréia e inchaço.
Em ambos os casos, opções por comida 'sem gluten' são essenciais. Mas se você não sofre
com nenhum dos casos, não existe muito apoio para outras melhoras de saúde com dietas sem gluten.
De nenhuma maneira é uma 'toxina' como alguns podem sugerir, e 'sem gluten' não significa necessariamente
que a comida é mais natural, saudável, ou possuí menos calorias.
Contrário a isso, existem alguns riscos em cortar o gluten da dieta; Enquanto falta de gluten em si
não é de se preocupar, as vitaminas e grãos que frequentemente são usados, são muito importantes.
Sem eles, você pode estar prejudicando sua própria saúde. No geral, sem o
gluten para juntar a sua comida toda, mais gordura e açúcar são usados em comidas 'sem gluten'
para torná-las mais agradáveis.
No mesmo tempo, a popularidade de dietas 'sem gluten' criou um mercado para
essas comidas. Onde antes tinha uma seleção pequena, agora existem opções 'sem gluten'
por todo lugar -  e isso é muito legal para aqueles que realmente precisam!
Mas e se existisse uma substância que incluísse tudo o que seu corpo necessita, e tirasse
tudo que não? Como uma dieta perfeita, tudo em um só? Venha conosco no
nosso segundo canal, AsapTHOUGHT, onde mostramos como no futuro, você nunca mais
vai precisar se preocupar com comida! Clique na sua tela, ou no link na descrição!
Tem alguma pergunta que quer respondida? Deixe nos comentários ou no Facebook e Twitter.
E se você quer uma espadinha em episódios futuros e 'Por trás das Câmeras',
Siga-nos no nosso Instagram e Twitter pessoais
E se inscreva para mais vídeos semanais de ciência!